literally
the vmas the met gala and now i heart
are you exhausted hell yeah
well i have to give you a huge
congratulations on your win at the vmas
what did that mean to you um
i felt very acknowledged so i just want
to give a special thank you on behalf of
me and my team nice where are you going
to keep your award
i don't know that's a good question i
haven't even thought of that
i feel like a nice shelf or i don't have
shelves in my house i have
i live in a condo i move from a house to
a condo to feel more safe
okay
well next time we we check in with you
i'm sure you'll have more awards too to
add to and then let me know where
they're they're kept hopefully on a
shelf a shelf sounds nice and clean and
organized i'll send some people from
home depot over we'll get we'll put some
shelves on your wall for all these
awards yes ma'am all right next up on
the list from vmas straight into met
gala how much fun did you have
i had a lot of fun it was my first time
at the med gala were you nervous hell
yeah
i was nervous my gala is like the
fashionistas of the fashionista so i was
so grateful to be invited and what
happened indoors inside that the cameras
didn't see i was hungry you were hungry
yes
we had kiki palmer tweeting that
there y'all just had like little
vegetables we definitely had vegetables
it wasn't even a full plate
i mean
but you still had a great job of course
of course definitely did you have any uh
benifer sightings in there oh i didn't i
didn't oh i didn't i know i wish i would
have knew no yeah i mean it was a
star-studded event left and right i feel
like you couldn't turn anywhere without
seeing someone definitely
so now here at iheart how excited are
you just to be in the presence of so
many amazing artists of all genres it's
crazy i'm just i'm just really happy to
be here i've been inside for a long time
so i'm outside and it feels good and you
performed earlier we have to talk about
the look because you had a little uh
something something happen
with uh your
look not arriving to vegas no but the
show must go on that's exactly what i
was going to tell you the show must go
on and you killed it you were in your
slippers right
yes
honestly one for the books it's
definitely like a melody yes so what is
next for you you're go go go will you
have some time to relax or is it right
into the next thing my album is next
pretty [ __ ] music is on the way pretty
much music is on the way well can you
tease everyone
i have some bomb ass features on there
oh my god you know i'm gonna ask you can
you tease us yeah i can't tell you no i
can't tell you do you want to keep it a
secret until it drops okay the vocals
gotta come in okay all right well we
will be waiting
very anticipated for it as soon as you
can tell us something let us know thank
you you look amazing you do too what
the red and the black i mean you look
like a tour honey it's couture you look
like a roulette table oh i like that
i'll take it
you